click the afterwards tab to find this
and all previous episodes
good afternoon and welcome everybody to
this afternoon's program at the
commonwealth club
my name is robert rosenthal and i'm a
board member and long time journalist
and i'm now a board member at the center
for investigative reporting
earlier in my career i did work in
philadelphia and we were not in the same
newspaper but we certainly just
reminisced about some places we loved in
philly
including cheese steaks
without julie's
really heroic journalistic efforts at
the miami herald
we may never have known what we know
today about jeffrey epstein
and while of course much remains a
mystery about epstein
we know more about his victims and the
failure of the judicial system than we
ever did because of julie's reporting
based on a reporting
julie's new book was published this week
perversion of justice the jeffrey
epstein's story
and it's uh it reads uh i'm sorry to say
it's not fiction but it's true but it
reads like a a novel and it's not only a
story
uh
about what it really takes to be do
great
investigative restore reporting it's a
story about passion taking risks
the challenges a single mom faced
doing this kind of work uh it's a story
about what's happened to the newspaper
industry in terms of its downsizing
and really it's a story about the role
of the press and a democracy and when
people like julie and miami herald
did what they did it truly makes a
difference
so i'm honored to be here today with
julie and i really hardly recommend this
book for a mirrored
reasons
so before we jump in a quick note about
today's format i'm particularly pleased
that today represents one of the
commonwealth club's first hybrid virtual
program since the club reopened earlier
this month
that means that we two things first we
have a live audience here in san
francisco hi everybody
and viewers around the country watching
vi via
youtube uh all of you no matter how you
are watching can submit questions to
either julie or me
if we are watching online please post
the questions in the chat format of
youtube or zoom
those will be brought to me throughout
the program for on-site questions we may
use one of the microphones
and we can we go to the audience as well
cards will also be written and brought
up to me
so julie as before we start i just want
to frame what we're going to do today
and i know you've had a lot of
interviews so give you two minutes to
rest
but i wanted to read from the preface in
your book because it sort of frames what
we're going to be talking about today
and
i thought it would just set up what
we're doing and this is julie wrote this
in the preface
uh this was only written a few months
ago this book as i said came out this
week
this is what julie wrote the jeffrey
epstein's story epitomizes our nation's
lopsided system of justice
and how victims of sexual assault
especially those who are young and poor
are discarded shamed and mistreated by
the very people who are supposed to
protect them
epstein got away with his crimes because
nearly every element of society allowed
him to get away with them professional
legal and moral ethics were set aside
for a broken system of values that
places corporate profits
personal wealth
political connections and celebrity
above some of the most sacred tenets of
our faiths our teachings in our
democracy
when i became a journalist i learned
that the most rewarding part of my work
was in writing injustices for those who
could not fight for themselves
few people seem to recognize that fc not
only beat the system but he was probably
still hunting terrorizing and abusing
young women and girls
i would face many obstacles on my path
to the truth
i would be attacked by the legal forces
who failed their solomos by the defense
attorneys who profited off of epstein's
crimes
by some of those within my own industry
who thought that what i was doing was
nothing more than a rehash of an old
story
so julie uh
you've been in this business a while and
uh like every great story it has a
beginning
can you take us to the point where you
first really got
hooked
into doing the story and also about some
of the events that already had
transpired that you may or may not have
been aware of
well in late 2016 we were um
i was in the middle of a
long-term investigation into florida
prisons
but it was winding down and i really
wanted to
to try to move on to something different
so
i
you know i had done some work in the
women's prison and i knew that sex
trafficking was a real problem in
florida
so i started doing some research on sex
trafficking in florida and every time i
googled those two subjects uh jeffrey
epstein's name popped up
i read a column by one of our former
columnist fred grimm um that really took
the
criminal justice system and the
prosecutors in this case to task for how
they handled it
nothing that i read seemed to make sense
of it it just here was a man who was
accused of molesting countless girls and
uh
you know he seemed to get away with a
slap on the wrist
wrist so i just started kind of picking
away at it and looking at it and as i
was doing that um requesting some public
records uh donald trump nominated a man
by the name of alex acosta to be his
label labor secretary
uh i was aware that a cop by that time i
was aware that acosta was the prosecutor
former miami prosecutor who had signed
off on this um
this
you know lenient plea deal for epstein
so
i watched
his confirmation hearings thinking he
was going to be grilled over this deal
and to my um surprise hardly any of the
senators really brought much of it up
and it was clear from the little bit
that they did question him about it that
they didn't understand this scope or the
breadth of this horrible um
this horrible deal that acosta had
signed off on and just
frame it a little bit because now you're
talking about a period that's uh eight
years after the deal is that right so
this is crap
this is laying dormant for eight years
and then you start poking at it again
now because it was one of those things
where i would read a story and i think
what how did this happen and none of the
stories that i read
answered how something like that could
happen
so i was curious about that fact
and then when this nomination happened i
thought
i wonder what the victims you know
this was a crime that happened 10 years
before this would mean that the victims
were now in their late 20s early 30s
and uh you know the labor secretary uh
post was one with oversight of human
trafficking and child labor laws and i
thought
i wonder what epstein's victims think
about um this man who had allowed their
predators essentially almost off the
hook
now taking over the reins of this huge
um department
so real the hook for you
was empathy and compassion and thinking
about these young women
and how they might be sitting here
thinking about what was going on
if they're aware of what acosta had done
in terms of cutting this plea deal with
with and letting epstein basically
almost walk
right and then i also saw that epstein
you know even though his crime he had
already served the short jail sentence
that he had been given many many years
before having been released in 2009 he
went back to his jet setting life it was
almost i realized it was almost as if he
got to go back to his normal everyday
life
um making money and and hobnobbing with
all these important people
and in my mind i'm thinking i bet the
girls you know who suffered this aren't
living the same lives that they had led
and that
in my mind i'm thinking i you know i
felt
a gut instinct that they were still
probably suffering trauma from this
at this point from the from the court
filings and documents that you're
looking at because
had you begun actually
you know human sourcing yet or you just
were looking and reading what you was on
the record
i was just at that point just looking
and reading the documents because it was
a very old case and i was looking for a
hook quite frankly if i wanted to do it
you know you always have to
tell give your pitch it to your editor
and you have to have you know some kind
of reason for for looking into a case
that's that old and it was just
coincidental that akasa was nominated
right around the time i was poking at it
number one and
and that um
you know i i also saw that there was one
lawsuit a simple lawsuit that was still
lingering
uh
that it seemed like why
it i wondered why it was hanging on
after all these years and did you at
that point know the name of any of these
young women or they're all jane doe's
in the in the filings they were all jane
doe's so take us through
okay so you're you've got this your gut
your tingling there's something wrong
here you have a hook in that the u.s
attorney
who had basically let this guy off and
in the documents you were looking at i
believe there were dozens of young women
who had alleged
that they had been uh or that the
detectives had found were going to
testify that they had been sexually
abused by jeffrey epstein and when they
were minors is that right
that's correct so you had dozens of
cases it wasn't one or two or three or
four you you and
i believe the documents hinted that
there were many more
that's right it seemed um
there was
information in the fbi the little bit of
fbi information that we had was that
these the fbi agents who were
investigating it
were interested in traveling to new york
and new mexico which were two other
places where epstein owned homes and
while it didn't say
why it was clear to me that they were
probably trying to find out whether he
had been abusing girls in these other
places
so you have a situation where some of
the people in law law enforcement
probably you're wondering where they
coerced or went along with this and
probably others from your experience you
know might have been outraged
what steps then you did you then take to
begin
finding the human the sources who could
be who did you who did you then go look
for
well i reached out to first of all i one
of the other things i noticed about it
was that the
uh you know as a police rep most of my
career was meant to be
spent being a police reporter crime
reporter so the first thing i thought
well the police you know who handled who
was the lead detective 10 years ago
who was the police chief and in doing my
research i learned that the
lead detected of the case joe ricari had
retired and so had the police chief mike
rider and uh yet they had never spoken
publicly at all about the case the only
public
uh information we had were two
depositions that they had given
many many years earlier um i think in
like 2010
um so these were even dated uh
interviews and they were court
depositions which as you probably know
are pretty boring documents um and uh i
i set out really first to try to get
them to go on the record so this yeah
i hope this conversation isn't too
inside the newsroom because what i'm
really trying to draw out here is how
one reporter
one person who's got instincts and
passion and guts
uh
and a very strong will
can truly make a difference and it
applies to many things in life so you
have you then go you have a couple of
names they've never spoken on the record
outside whatever they did in a document
and
how do you go about finding them and
then convincing them based on probably
their own cynicism about no one's going
to do anything about this what's the
process and how long did that take
well that process took a lot longer than
i expected um
you know i think my editor was getting a
little antsy because it was taking so
long i was trying to explain look these
victims names aren't in any of the
documents
it's just going to be a a painstaking
process to go through all the documents
and basically what i did was started
reading everything and you know
uh
doing this as i said so many years it's
inevitable that they miss a name
you know or they have the first name and
not the last name or they have the first
name and then the date of birth so it
was this big puzzle and i did a
spreadsheet and i would put what
information i had on each victim you
know it would only be scraps of
information
and from those scraps of information um
i looked at some of the uh a lot of
these women had sued epstein in the
years since this happened um of course
they were all listed as jane does but i
would have to read each of those uh
lawsuits in order to get it i had a file
for jane doe juan jane doe two jane doe
all the way up to 120 something and uh
so i would just keep filling these files
and i use social media you know a lot of
these uh women for example if i found
one woman on facebook uh let's just say
she was um you know jan smith
i could look at her friends on facebook
and you know it's really kind of creepy
at times because epstein had a certain
kind of type he liked very um petite um
blonde hair blue eyed i mean they are
they looked very similar um so i would
just basically look at their friends who
all look you know that look like that
and slowly i began to piece together uh
i had a you know i just the list just
goes by now you know that in the initial
go round uh in 2005 six seven
when epstein was dealing with this and
basically got off very leniently
he brought in lawyers like kenneth starr
and alan dershowitz you knew you were
going up against
internship you know spaceship galactica
galactica right
did that i mean what did that mean
signal to you also
well it signaled to me that i better let
our executive editor know what i was
doing
uh
so i i you know knocked on um
mindy's um mindy marquez uh
was our executive editor at the time
and um
you know i said look uh do you have a
second i want to tell you what i'm
working on and
so we just talked about the case and i
told them this is this is gonna might be
a rough one because we're going up some
very powerful people and he has
a legal arsenal that
you know that potentially
would threaten to sue us
and but i told her the story and i told
her about the the women and he
ultimately said go for it
and you would and it so this is around
what point 2017
yeah really
yeah and so you're you're basically
going through months and months of
reading documents trying to figure out
how to find these jane does getting
sources
mccarty ritter the the former law
enforcement the the chief and this is in
palm beach again
uh to try and speak to you
and that's months of work is that right
yeah
tracking down the women was the most
time consuming and and trying to get
them to talk was the most time-consuming
part so let me let me ask you a question
because you know in the book you you
weave in
uh something that i found really
interesting and surprising
uh your own story
you know your family comes in you're a
single mom
your kids become almost second you know
characters uh
and you also talk about your own
upbringing did did you
were you conscious of the fact that
there was something in there that
did you ever think i could have been one
of these girls
you know i didn't i wasn't conscious of
it when i started the project at all i
didn't become conscious of it until i
started interviewing women and
especially uh you know i interviewed a
couple of their moms
and
the stories that their moms told me
reminded me use of my own mother you
know in the struggle she had as a single
mom and
you know quite frankly i you know i had
a tough growing up and i had put it out
of my head it was sort of like a a
reckoning of my own without me really
planning on it that way that i just
started thinking about wow i remember
when my mom had to you know work two
jobs she was a waitress part-time and
she wasn't home a whole lot and
you know we were left we were latchkey
kids you know and
you know
you know as i said it slowly dawned on
me that i had
a lot in common with these women but i
didn't do this story for that reason i
just you know it was just it just kind
of happened that way
well you know some of the best
journalists you have tremendous
compassion and
and there are victims in any situation
you want to be able to tell their story
and hopefully make it relevant so other
people can understand what they went
through
and that really came through julie take
us through i mean the reporting here and
it's hard to explain i think to a
non-journalist audience that's you know
i don't know how many thousands of pages
these documents you read
trying to track people down uh i know
one of the heroines in the story is the
librarian
i think her name was uh
yeah monica
yeah she monica layal
yeah i i felt that i feel so feel that
librarians don't get a lot of credit in
our business
and they're very important um to what we
do um the other real heroine also was my
uh partner emily michaud who was my
videographer and photographer who
uh worked on this project from with me
from the get-go and was a real uh
important
uh you know it's important to un to hear
this story
uh we work we put together the
documentaries as well as to see the
story as much as it is to read the story
uh she made these women very um
three-dimensional and and very um
you know
no one could tell the story really
better than the women themselves and
these documentaries did that well and i
think i want to get to that sort of the
interview process but
is was there a point in this early
reporting where you suddenly felt
outrage
or
pretty much from the beginning you know
i i just couldn't
i it i was outraged from the very
beginning i just couldn't understand how
someone like that could have gotten away
with this
uh and that's what made me want to do it
because i to be honest with you i felt
like it was like an unsolved crime
that i had to solve and i thought i knew
a lot had been written about it but as i
said i don't think the answers were
really known so i set out to really
solve this mystery
and you knew i think that you had to get
as many of these young women now a
little older
on the record to tell their story
so can you take could you can you take
this
yeah can you can you take us through
how you found the first couple of women
and and what you know what you know what
you had to do to get them their trust
and i think
again one of the most difficult things a
reporter a journalist has to do is uh
speak to people who've lost something
victims of something in this case uh
sexual abuse or rape is is really
difficult
to win the trust and the sensitivity you
need to do that but can you just take it
through the process and and that some of
the first meetings
well i before i even met with them i
i
hadn't intentively i knew that this was
going to be an issue where i was going
to be asking these women whom i had
never met before
about the worst
time of their life and i knew that some
of them had probably never told anybody
that this had happened they were very
young
and i was concerned that i was going to
perhaps re-traumatize them so i you know
i spoke with some people who do these
kinds of interviews for a living
to get some
insight into how to handle it and one of
the things that i concluded was that i
didn't need to force them to talk about
the abuse you know the physical abuse
that it was more important that i
that i you know tell them look you don't
have to talk about this there's no
question that this happened you know fc
never denied that he did any of this
that was the other thing he never denied
he did it he once compared
what he did to
stealing a bagel you know he just didn't
think what he did
that he did anything wrong
so there was never a question that this
had happened so i didn't need for them
to tell me about the rapes um i just
needed them to talk about what it had
done to them and how they
you know were treated by the criminal
justice system
take take us through the first interview
with with emily and what you know what
that was like and your own feelings
well first of all the one thing i did i
i started thinking
this would be like any other story you
go knock on the door and um you tell the
person that you want to interview what
you want to talk to them about and then
i it you know when i did that
one of the women's fathers answered the
tour and i thought oh my gosh this isn't
going to work because i can't tell her
father why i'm there you know she might
not even know
so i i had i did another story before
that where i um wrote the victim of a
slain navy seal i wrote his father a
letter explaining what i wanted to do
and and it and the father did call me
and i got an exclusive interview with
them and
uh
i so i wrote 60 letters you know to all
the women that at that time that i had
tracked down and
um included what i wanted to do i
included a a couple of clips about how
epstein um had already tried to get his
sex offender registration lowered in new
york so he's trying to really
weasel you know uh out of any kind of um
restrictions that were placed on him
after he got out of jail
so i i wrote all these letters and i got
one
woman
called me um michelle likada who lived
outside of nashville
and she confessed to me that her lawyer
told her not to call me and our lawyer
told her not to talk to me
and
i just had a you know a talk with her on
the phone and i told her what i wanted
to do and
she said okay come and emily and i
didn't know when we set out for uh to
travel to tennessee whether she was
actually going to go through with it
because we knew she had some misgivings
and um
we we sat there we interviewed her for
oh gosh it had to be at least three
hours
uh
and it was just extremely emotional um
you know
emily and i really i think didn't really
understand the depth
of the trauma that that she and and
other women had gone through she only
went to epstein one time by the way
and it just with that one time it it
really almost destroyed her life and to
hear her tell and that's one of the
powerful
parts of the book i mean i touched upon
that and emily of course did a brilliant
job of it in the in the documentary but
you only get so many
you know minutes in a documentary and so
many inches in a story
so in the book i was able to really talk
about that whole interview and
you know and with each of these women
their whole story because it's important
to understand that um yes these girls
took money but they were really um
misled uh and they were really um
you know
why don't you
go into the detail of what the method
was i mean i i don't want to assume
everybody understands what was happening
here how
how this his system basically worked and
how there was it wasn't just jeffrey
epstein there was a whole infrastructure
around him
and many many people were aware of what
were going on can you just just
describe that for us what was actually
the methodology
yeah
jeffrey epstein had a whole ecosystem
around him of people that helped him i
mean he was a guy that really didn't
even tie his own shoelaces he had uh you
know he had somebody to do everything
for him and so these people
uh that were part of his uh
you know his his his life
you know or this this system that he had
built uh were you know involved everyone
from the butler who answered the door
with where these girls were to a chef
who was in the kitchen who you know made
them snacks to the women of course uh he
had other young women who arranged his
schedule to the um you know the the the
housekeepers who cleaned up after you
know he did
these incidents and
uh the pilots who flew
the jets you know where
he had two private planes uh the driver
he had a he had drivers you know that
that picked up the girls so it was a
whole ecosystem around him of people
that um
that really aided
um and helped this move well also i
think the book in the book you really
describe how in some cases you the
actual the first meeting where somebody
a young girl
she might be a runaway she might be in
distress she's somewhere she needs help
you had it was almost as if you had you
know
a wounded animal or you know i don't
mean that but just somebody and people
out looking
for the girls
who fit a physical description that he
he was sought after i mean they were out
right hunting really
that was by design i mean he could have
had the
most sophisticated expensive prostitutes
that his money could buy but that's not
what he wanted he wanted scared little
girls that was you know what he wanted
and he didn't even want them
um one one or two he wanted a revolving
door of them all the time you know that
was part of his sickness
and uh
so he like i said he he just had and
then you know the the
most insidious thing part of this of all
was when these girls of course became
like
you know scared and they didn't want to
do it he said oh don't worry about it
you don't have to do it just bring me
your friends and i'll pay you the same
amount of money so he had the girls that
he victimized didn't want to be
victimized anymore but they needed the
money for whatever reason they they were
on the street or they were in a foster
home
um and
they just would bring go to parties and
bring their friends or bring not even
people that were their friends people
that they would meet acquaintances that
they met in the mall you know or
at the gym or wherever so
he had you know he had a whole legion of
of recruiters
yeah and we're not even really getting
into the uh
the men in some cases the women who
surrounded him some of the most best
known people politicians
businessmen
uh you know corporate leaders uh who
were part of this world in some way and
i guess that's still one of the on
unclear mysteries um can you you know
there's so much to go to here uh
you know and i i want to sort of try and
keep it a little bit of chronology but
can you also you know one of the things
that also was quite revelatory in the
book
was your exploration of the two islands
and the virgin islands can you talk
about that and and sort out what was
going on there and how that was part of
this world of of jeffrey epstein and his
friends and what also
his method of
indebting himself to local officials and
government people either through
philanthropy or donations or building
something
uh this sort of almost 360 degree
system he created
right
well he couldn't have picked a better
place um
to
you know further his crimes than this
island that he bought off the coast of
st thomas uh the only way you can get to
it is uh by helicopter or by boat um and
he
he
you know it's also a place where the
people on st thomas are pretty poor um
and
um the politicians um
you know he ingratiated himself with it
with the government officials and the
politicians uh the wife of the then
governor went to work for epstein i
think she worked for him for for many
years like 10 years
uh so he and then he uh donated you know
tens of thousands maybe even um you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars to uh
build schools there uh you know donated
built you know the first
music school
uh soccer programs i mean you just name
it it was just anything that he could
throw his money at so um inevitably you
know uh these people came to you know
know him as somebody as somewhat of a
benefactor and they you know turn their
eye you know turn their heads the other
way when he was bringing in all these
girls on his on his private plane he
would fly into the airport at st thomas
on his private plane
and then
go to a hangar you know an area that
wasn't real completely visible to
everyone
um
disembark with the girls and then they
would usually hop on a helicopter that
was kept there and then they they would
be flown to the island and one of the
things you that you were i think still
looking for and maybe you're still
looking for are manifests
is that right who flew on these flights
and also who flew around and you've been
unable to get a lot of those right in
other words who he was flying with
and homeland security has blocked that
is that still true
yeah because unfortunately when i
started doing this this was after my
series ran and i was trying to get
information on that and i first did the
public records request before epstein's
arrest i did get some of it uh but it
was heavily redacted and before i could
pressure and get anything more about it
he was arrested and then of course
uh then it was an open criminal
investigation and i wasn't going to get
anything
um i'm told i need to just move my light
a little closer here it's getting dark
here in florida and and so let me just
move my light excuse me
this is better
okay how's that a little bit better
anyway
well you look good to me
so i mean i can see you
but so i mean so since the uh
is that because of his death though is
that stuff now sealed or can you can
anyone get at it
i don't want to keep anything i don't
think they're going to give us anything
on that um
you know i because i i know he's he's
gone now but the case is still open and
theoretically i guess they're still
looking at other people besides even
uh
maxwell who who is indicted and connect
with
his his sex trafficking operation
you know one of the things to switch
direction a little bit julie in the book
uh and i mentioned it earlier
what was your thinking
as a
reporter i mean a lot of times
in traditional journalism you sort of
i'll call it behind the curtain you know
you don't get into your life your ups
and downs
the challenges of being a single mom was
was that a decision you wanted to make
was that your editor your book editor
can you get into because your children
as i said earlier
and there's some wonderful scenes there
as a parent you know uh
uh
why why did you do that
well my editor um
i you know it was partially my editor
thought that this story
um and i i fought it actually i didn't
want to do that initially i said look
i'll do this i really don't i don't want
to be in the story you know and
then as i was working on it i you know
this was around the time of you know
trump
um
and all the things that he was tweeting
out that weren't true and uh the the
journalists being painted as the enemy
of the people and
uh you know after this series ran i was
one of the biggest surprises to me was
how much
uh
fan mail quite frankly that i got you
know journalists never get fan mail uh
but just a lot of um
you know thank you notes from people
saying you know finally this is what
journalism is and and this is why it's
important
and it occurred to me that you know
journalists aren't always very good at
telling people what we do and how we go
about it we just do it and i do think
that at this time in history that it's
important that we explain to people what
we do because uh for you know because of
trump and because of all the things that
have happened i think uh a good deal of
america has become distrustful of
journalists
and so
i i thought maybe i should tell them
what i did so they understand this isn't
you know
this isn't an effort
to um you know to cover anything up this
is an effort to find the truth and
that's i think what most journalists
do you know and and so i thought
i'm going to put a little bit of this in
here because
i just i think it's part it's important
for our country and especially given the
fact that newspapers you know small
newspapers all over this country are
disappearing you know and i don't think
the public realizes
how um devastating that is to our
democracy that we're losing small
newspapers all over the country
well i
here here i agree uh
your work certainly shows the difference
you can make
uh
the you know one of the and it's it's
really complicated to get into i mean
the perversion of justice you know
is i think a perfect title because once
you get into this and you see
all the things that happen and it's
probably pretty complicated to explain
it here in terms of the system
and the players you talk about and some
of the stuff you had access to and
explaining
decisions that were made to protect
jeffrey epstein and also
one of the things we haven't talked
about
was the ferocity of his attorneys
going after the victims
yeah and which is
appalling when you read about it and i
don't can you talk a little bit about
that and that what that did to some of
these young women in addition to the
initial trauma
well just imagine you're 14 years old
and you did something horrible that you
are very ashamed of and the police find
out about it and they come and they
knock on your door and they you want to
talk to you and of course you got to
explain to your parents why the police
are
talking to you and you have to confess
look i went to this guy's house i i
thought i was just giving him a massage
and here's what happened and then when
that after that happens the next thing
you know you have um you know a man that
you don't even know um just either
following you or or
knocking or coming into the little you
know bagel shop where you work and and
coming and your boss is standing there
and it's official looking man and he
said we need to talk to you and then it
turns out it's a private investigator
that's working for jeffrey epstein and
they want to sit down with you and then
they tell you look if you uh basically
they tell you if you work with us you'll
be fine and if you don't work with us
then uh you're not going to be fine and
your family might not be fine
or or your father is followed and he
there's headlights in his rearview
mirror and he you know
they run him off the road i mean this
this was really happening with these
victims and the fact that prosecutors
knew that it was happening and they
didn't do anything to stop it
uh is is just um
i don't even know what the words were
for it i was just so uh
shocked
have any of those people
you been held to account i know several
lost their jobs after your stories came
out but in the after initial go around
really nothing happened to anybody
no
no i you know what the only people um
really who have paid a price in this
whole thing are women uh from the
victims to um
you know even the prosecutors uh the pro
and
the prosecutors
that advocated for them this both the
state lead state prosecutor and the
federal prosecutor were women right um
but um you know the cases went nowhere
because their bosses who happen to all
be men um
sort of you know excuse what he did and
said look these victims aren't credible
uh they're prostitutes
uh you know um it wasn't a big deal
um you know there were all these excuses
that were made
yeah can you i'm getting more maybe talk
about i mean in every story there's also
an editor who sometimes is behind the
curtain
uh you your interactions with casey
frank are quite
candid
and your thoughts about editors are
pretty candid i didn't take any umbrage
uh but talk about casey frank and the
relationship you had and how that either
helped or hindered or you know the whole
back and forth
well you know it's
it's you know journalism it can be very
messy and especially when you have two
headstrong people i'm very headstrong
and you know i'm quite candid about
myself as well i said you know that i'm
a hard person to deal with myself uh you
know i um i wasn't always you know i was
an editor at one point like
not long because i wasn't very good at
it and
uh i
i was tough you know
to some reporters and i regret it um
and so it is this
this dynamic where you're sometimes you
know at you know at cross purposes
and uh
casey's been my editor for for probably
the whole almost the entire time uh 13
years i've been at the herald uh we are
almost always on the same page with the
kind of stories that we think are
important but sometimes the way that you
know i want to go about it isn't the way
that he thinks i should go about it so
and i as i said i'm pretty stubborn and
headstrong and so is he sometimes so we
clashed and um i was honest about that
and
um
i don't know i just i i
you know in the end um in my
acknowledgements i said however you know
he
we would have never had some of the
stories that we had if that didn't
happen that the same thing that made us
clash i think were the was the very
thing that made our stories
um so important and so um
you know
i mean we just covered all the bases
because
we had to we had to come together in the
end for the sake of the story were you
able to share your your fears i mean
literal fears that you and emily had
during this process and what did he do
to either swage them or help you what
kind of did you set up a system in case
strange things happened or the knock at
the door that type of thing well you
know it's funny
i had some
you know i had some weird things happen
with the prison stories that i had done
i remember calling casey uh one time
you know after someone had showed up in
my apartment in the middle of the night
i was pretty s scared during the prison
series the epstein series i don't know
for whatever reason i didn't it i it
didn't really spook me until af well
after well after the series ran and i
was deep into it
so i didn't really have a reason to talk
to him about that
uh emily however uh
it was a lot different than i am she she
was a lot more um paying attention to to
what was going on i was a little bit
more busy about the story we're two
different personalities that way so
we're a good balance with each other but
she would be like are you crazy why
would you do that you know so and the
book goes into a couple of those
anecdotes about emily and i with her
throwing the furniture in front of the
hotel room door and me just falling
asleep because i'm thinking whatever
emily uh
i you know like i said it wasn't until
after
you know we knew that it was really
serious that that that now epstein was
going to be arrested or you know the
congress had asked for a
justice department investigation that's
when
weird things started happening you know
people showing up uh van parked in front
of emily's house around the clock
people um showing up outside my
apartment which is not an easy
place to to you know it's not a place
that people would be walking by you have
to go in an elevator and come up and you
know it was just odd things look i
firmly believe that um there were people
that were investigating emily and i it
just they had to because
uh
the case had just gotten so hot and
epstein from
the beginning after the series ran
was
afraid that he was going to be charged i
just know that because some people
around him told me he was worried he was
going to be charged
you explained bruce springsteen's role
in your work
[Laughter]
um you know just whenever i have a lot
of anxiety
i just i always turn him on and uh just
listen to him means you know after a
long day writing and
uh you know i i grew up as you you know
we mentioned earlier in philadelphia and
i spent my summers at the jersey shore
and
it just you know he's a great
storyteller you know he's brilliant and
i think his stories just helped make me
um he comforted me in some way and so
especially when i was writing the book i
was listening i i would after a long day
of writing i
just would turn on uh serious radio and
just play him the whole entire night to
the point that my kids were like rolling
their eyes like please mom do we have to
really listen to bruce springsteen again
you know kind of thing so it was it was
kind of part of the you know the fabric
of my life when this story was unfolding
and you know it's a very dark story it's
a very um
you know people said how did how did you
do this this is really like a uh you
know you could really get depressed
doing this and i think just it was
something that helps keep me going kind
of
yeah it is a dark story and i'm going to
get back to darkness now uh near the end
of the book one of the chapters is
did jeffrey epstein did not kill himself
uh
so
that's a statement and i so can you
explain and take us through
either the process of using that
headline or that title chapter chapter
title or
is that something you believe
i this is what i think i i used it sort
of because that's what everybody was it
was sort of a thing that was all over um
you know social media and everywhere i
mean in our culture you know you turned
on tv it was there and the mardi gras
parade my son went to mardi gras and
they had a float of jeffrey epstein
jeffrey epstein did not commit suicide
it became this i don't know this mantra
and
you know i did look at this and people
would always ask me when i was doing uh
i was doing a lot of college talks at
this time journalism classes and people
would ask me and
you know i had to be honest with myself
i i really didn't think he had he was
capable of of committing suicide by
himself now could he have um could it
have been assisted suicide yes um i i
think if we want to think that that he
wanted to end it
i think someone must have helped him i
just don't think he was capable i mean
and i'm not the only one that thinks
this his brother thinks that his lawyers
think that uh the forensic pathologist
that was at the autopsy doesn't believe
that he killed himself um you know there
are just too many
strange things that happened i mean
uh he had three bones broken in his neck
and dr michael baden the forensic
pathologist at the autopsy said you
rarely in in that kind of a
uh hanging have three bones broken in
your neck keep in mind the theory was
that he
he um did this with the bed sheets um
cutting these
up and then he
kind of
pulled himself against the bunk he tied
it to the top bunk and he would have had
to pull himself with such though i mean
there really wasn't according to bottom
enough velocity enough
room there for him to have done this and
broken three bones and
you know the toiletries that were on top
of his bunk weren't even disturbed
so um and then you have two guards that
are asleep at the wheel then you have
video disappear then you find out that
you know the guy that was in the cell
with him was taking that taken out just
hours before this happened i mean it's
just too i you know i've done crime
reporting and especially prison deaths
for a long time
and my god just tells me that that this
was not you know
just a suicide that he did by himself
well the way you wrote that chapter is
certainly all these questions you're
raising are laid out in a really
coherent way now there is some there is
an inquiry isn't there is or is that the
us attorney's office is supposed to be
doing something is new york on is that
happening or do you have any idea new
york is looking at um you know the two
corrections officers that were on duty
um already struck a plea deal so they're
quiet here we go again with everything
that's being sealed and nobody's talking
about that part of it and then there's a
separate justice department
investigation by the inspector general
of the justice department that is still
ongoing i don't know why it's taking
this long uh
so that's still open so you know
and even if the ruling comes out
whatever that ruling is i don't know
whether the evidence will ever be made
public
yeah that's the as you alluded to what
what let's you know jump more to the
present now uh
slain maxwell uh
will you be covering her trial and what
do you think will be coming out of that
well
um
gailan maxwell is sort of taking a page
out of the jeffrey epstein defense
playbook in that she's hired some very a
team of very high powered lawyers who
have
uh justice previous experience in the
justice department and
uh you know they are bombarding the
prosecutors with all kinds of paperwork
you know motions and
uh just anything that they can kind of
throw at the wall hoping that it's going
to um
you know they're looking for uh some
kind of a loophole they're
they're they're going to inevitably
argue that she was part of that original
you know in the original uh deal that
epstein struck in 2008 there was this
strange
uh sort of codicil to the deal where uh
he uh his co-conspirators four of whom
were named there were four women who
helped him with the schedule uh were
given immunity as well as well as some
unnamed people that we still don't know
who they were
and
that her lawyers will argue that she was
one of those people now whether that'll
stick
remains to be seen
yeah i mean acosta really shows up in
this again and again and there's you
know the
justice department i mean one of the
details in the book
he wrote
did a review and basically found him
making
guilty of poor judgment but no ethical
lapses and then there's a footnote in
that report
that says that
many of his emails have vanished
yeah i mean they have they didn't say
anybody else has
disappeared
it's not just his emails it's his emails
during the period when this deal
was done
have vanished so
you know
i guess it wasn't like they said well he
had a major
loss of all his emails it was the emails
during the period when this deal was
negotiated that disappeared
yeah
so in epstein's will which he wrote a
couple of days before he was found dead
right he he listed his net worth i think
what he's 578 million
now
i think you said it in the end of the
book and these numbers may have changed
that a victim's compensation fund was
created
and that i think you said 175 women have
filed claims as alleged victims and so
forth 67 million has been paid out
so
those women you were aware of or what's
the process there can you talk about
that
well we don't really know a lot about
them but i know some of the lawyers who
represented them and these are women
some of whom by the way um
have said that epstein
essentially trafficked them out to some
of these important men
but they are afraid to come forward
i mean you look at someone like alan
dershowitz who has
attacked the woman that was um that
accused him uh for years i mean he has
sued her he has
i mean
he has made her life
really uh miserable and i even got
dur when this was happening i even got
um emails and a couple of phone calls
from some people
who knew alan dershowitz
and said
that they would never say anything about
what they know because they're we're
afraid of them you know and
that's what these women's uh these
attorneys who represent some of these
women said that they
they're never going to go public because
they're too afraid of what the men
uh will put them through
yeah when you read the book the list of
men who allegedly were involved here is
fairly astonishing
uh
and the denial's everywhere and then
also
what seems to be some very strong
evidence from some of these women and
also the pattern the pattern is there
it's not like necessarily even one-offs
i mean you really established patterns
here which you must have seen in the
reporting
yes i you know it took a while to put a
lot of it together because not all of it
was in one place
you know there were different um you
know there was a state investigation the
federal investigation and the fbi report
then the civil lawsuits and so there
were a lot of different pieces and and i
think that that's another thing um
another piece of that that i kind of put
together in this book because you know
when you're
when you're doing a piece like this
there's
so much information and you can't always
put it everything in the story so this
kind of delves more into some of those
details that i could include in the
original story
you know for you do you do you feel like
you're
done with this or are you look you still
want to be engaged i mean now you're i
guess you're starting a book tour or at
least a virtual book tour you i'm sure
you're exhausted uh
you know you know i want to see it
through uh but i i'm also mindful you
know
one of the other things i talk about in
this book is how i was on other stories
you know some people said well it must
be nice to do that nothing else well
that's not how it worked i i was doing
the parkland uh shootings i was doing
the shooting at the fort lauderdale
airport um i was covering other things
when this happened and you know we just
unfortunately had this horrible tragedy
here in surfside and um
you know
when we're you know
when you work for a paper you know a
smaller paper you just don't have the
luxury of just going off on one
thing i probably have a little bit more
of that luxury than other reporters but
um
you know you you really have to to
to join in on the coverage you just have
to yeah i'll give you for the audience
some context you know
20 years ago or so julie would have been
what they called detached
just to work on this and had the freedom
to do it but these days those news rooms
are about probably the fifth of what
they were so
sometimes it's all hands in even on when
she's in the middle of a huge and
important story like this so again
i just think it's uh speaks volumes
about
your persistence and your
work ethic and your determination uh to
do this and i you know i know what how
difficult that is and i respect the hell
out of it
um
you know there's some here's a question
from the audience uh and you've touched
on it a couple of times
but what are some of the questions
remaining mysteries you know about what
jeff epstein that you wonder about and
that you have any potential hope
anything will come out
to lose threads
for all that i mean
uh
you know i i
i think one of the things um for example
is
you know didn't anybody keep track here
was a guy who who was a
convicted sex offender accused of
molesting girls and he gets out of jail
in 2009 and nobody's paying attention to
where he's flying his plane and who's on
his plane i mean it's just mind-boggling
to me
does anybody watch these people when
they get out you know and make sure that
they're not you know getting other girls
from you know eastern europe and
bringing them to our country it just
seemed to me that he wasn't having any
problems after he got out of jail he
returned to his regular life and no one
was paying any attention to him
so you know that's one thing i think
should absolutely be looked at i mean
why weren't they checking his plane when
he got off in st thomas and asking those
girls how old they were
yeah that that one really jumped out and
i think in the book you also show that
there were there were in fact young
women or girls
brought from overseas
uh to new york
and then the who's who can you go can
you talk a little bit about the who's
who
uh of the mansion in new york and also
one of the details i think in one of the
hearings to
not give him bail when he was still
alive
was that the assistant u.s attorney
described how in the manhattan mansion
they were they found hundreds of
thousands not thousands hundreds of
thousands of photographs
of semi-nude you know 13 14 15 year old
girls
and i don't know what that indicated and
also a trove of diamonds
you know it is safe i mean uh but what i
mean the new york mansion also i mean
well we know you write about some of the
people who went there including bill
gates and i think you know other elected
officials
prince andrew and um
you know um
you know and the people that flew on his
plane you know
bill clinton um trump flew on his plane
um you know all these people were in and
out of uh
you know his life over this time period
when he was involved with this sex
trafficking operation
um
you know
the victims some of them have accused
some of the men of being involved um of
course we you know
this is a crime that you know doesn't
really have any witnesses you know when
you're in a room with a man doing this
to you there's really nobody there
to cooperate it except for of course
epstein who's gone now and um
you know there's been a lot of talk of
videos whether whether he had videos um
you know compromise on some of these men
i mean we really don't know for sure
i've heard different things from
different people
uh
but you know it makes you wonder whether
anybody else is really going to be held
accountable
are you still getting tips and leads on
this from people out of the blue
yes
i just got a couple this week because
the book is getting some press and i'm
hearing from people saying you know call
me i i know this so i'll call them all
and you know
see if any there's any truth to to you
know their tips um
usually as you know when you have a
story like this you know i would say
80
90 percent of them are
are not good good information but you if
you get one or two percent that that
make a difference one of the tips that i
did get after this series ran was the
one about the st thomas airport um our
traffic controller had called me or a
friend i should clarify it was a friend
of an air traffic controller who told
him that this air traffic controller had
seen him disembark his plane with a
bunch of girls well
talking about sources you you write a
chapter there about a couple of really
sketch characters uh patrick kessler and
mark dugan i mean those two i mean
what do you make of that i mean it was
almost like they were planted or they
were just
what do you think i just had to include
it because the story is so bizarre it's
almost like if you did a movie about it
you wouldn't believe that these
characters actually existed but they
really did and you know the new york
times did a whole um you know story
about the patrick kessler which i knew
about it as it was unfolding
but
you know quite a few people told me that
they thought he was a phony so i just
kept thinking
uh you know
why is the new york times still pursuing
it because everything i was hearing
anything tell us a little detail about
what that what he was up to
he claimed that he had video that
somehow he had gotten a hold of these uh
long lost epstein video that he had uh
either helped epstein i'm trying to
remember the details but he had helped
epstein catalog them or hide them or
something to that effect
uh the name he was you know a made-up
name uh he
he basically uh showed some of the
stills from the video he had to
uh two of the lawyers that represented
uh virginia dufresne who's uh one of the
victims
and
it implied that you know that this was
finally evidence against some of these
famous men and it was these videos of
some of these famous men uh that were
allegedly involved and ultimately he
never produced it the lawyers wanted to
authenticate the videos that he claimed
he had and he never produced them and he
just disappeared so you know
you know the thought was that he it was
just a phony you know and you have
several characters throughout the book
who
raise allegations
disappear and i and it's almost you i
think a couple of times you say that
it was almost could have been entrapment
also from from
lawyers i suspect that they were trying
to prep um david boyes who um
you know represented virginia and was
the nemesis and remains the nemesis of
alan dershowitz who
you know
right after that happened he filed a
motion in his court case against
virginia that you know
involving this patrick kessler thing
about how boys had tried to you know
use this somehow uh to
blackmail him or others which was really
uh my
research and my you know interview
showed that was not the case i was
talking to david boyes while this was
happening and david was telling me the
guy is a fake
so um
you know it's just i think just the
whole story is filled with these
characters and
these connections and in the middle of
it all are these
women that that really have never found
justice
and that's the sad part about this
yeah i think there are
uh
actually some hero lawyers as well or
who did the right thing i mean we didn't
really talk about brad edwards who i
think was really crucial to this in
terms of the civil suit
cases he filed and hopefully the reader
people will read the book and learn that
but i do want to end and we're getting
near the end uh a couple of questions
near the end of the book you talk about
the reckoning
that's the chapter and
in that some of the young women actually
it's not that they're
they find retribution or whatever but or
even healing but they're they're given
an opportunity can you talk about that
and that scene in that courtroom
yeah it was right after epstein um died
and
uh they were gonna it was just a
you know normally this kind of hearing
is just a formality it was to just for
the judge to drop the case essentially
there was no more case because he had
died
but the judge wanted to give the women
an opportunity to say their peace to
speak about what had happened to them so
quite a number of them showed up for
this hearing and the first thing you
notice is they were very still very
similar in the way they carried
themselves and they looked they were you
know you could tell they had model
postures and they
uh they were very slim and most of them
were blonde and um
so it was like you could tell because
they were all looked alike and i think
that you know i i you know quite frankly
i went to the ladies room one time and i
could hear them talking to each other
and they're sort of saying yeah i
remember you do you remember this and uh
they had this they were starting to form
this bond they had been through
something so horrible together and some
of them had never met each other before
but they knew some of the same women or
they knew
maxwell or they knew uh people that were
in that orbit that had um answered the
door or helped schedule them so they
were finding this common
ground that was and they were using it
to support each other yeah and that day
in court they were actually able to
testify to what had happened to them not
in the specific detail of the an act but
just the process and who they were
brought to him
that they were victims they were
testifying as victims really for the
first time
and i think in the courtroom there were
dozens that day and only a few ended up
testifying is that right
that's right um well there were quite a
number who who who spoke out they not
all of them wanted to identify
themselves
which was understandable it was very
emotional
you know some of them and i go into this
in my book some of the stories that they
told were were horrendous you know about
how they were taken advantage of i'm not
just talking about sexually but mentally
the mental aspect of this is is just as
important almost almost as important a
component of what he did he he mentally
manipulated them
well as a society now we're hearing more
and more about this unfortunately and uh
we this is the last question julie i
know you've been going all day and it's
evening in miami
uh
is there going to be a movie and who's
going to play you
oh gosh i i
there's going to be a um
hbo uh adam mckay the director um
is working on a
uh series a limited series for hbo about
it and uh i'm helping with the the
script i'm being interviewed all the
time by the screenwriter and uh we
always joke on who's gonna play me and i
i just
you know uh
you know i don't know you know i guess
um maybe you have a new career on the on
the big screen
i don't think so i don't think so i'm
not very uh articulate as you can tell
from this interview oh you've been great
well we're going to end it now and i i
really truly want to thank you for your
work uh you've made a big difference uh
you've had a great career and i'm sure
there's a lot ahead of you and you've
overcome
your persistence in overcoming obstacles
uh
as i said is inspirational for a lot of
people
and journalists especially
we could have gone much longer and i
just recommend the book for anybody and
i want to thank you for joining us today
for this really important conversation i
want to thank our audience here in san
francisco and online around the country
the program today will be available as a
video and podcast on the club's website
www.commonwealthclub.org
and i'm robert rosenthal
and now this meeting of the commonwealth
club the place where you're in the know
is adjourned have a good evening
see you
bye-bye
[Applause]
here's a look at some new books being
published this week
former south carolina